okay welcome to the ddps seminar
everyone before we introduce our invited
speaker let's go over some rules and
Logistics now first of all please mute
yourself during the talk unless you have
questions if you have questions you're
welcome to unmute and ask otherwise
please use chat room to post your
questions so that we can address them in
training session at the end second
today's gdps seminar is open to external
audiences therefore no classified
discussion is allowed so please watch
out finally The Talk today will be
recorded and uploaded in our YouTube
channel that's about it now let me
introduce our speaker today
it is a great honor to host the Ralph
Smith who is a distinguished University
professor of mathematics at North
Carolina State University he is
co-author of the research monograph
smart material structures modeling
estimation and control and author of the
books
smart material systems model development
and uncertainty quantification Theory
implementation and applications
he is on the editorial Boards of the
Journal of intelligent material systems
and structures and the Siam journal on
uncertainty uncertainty quantification
he is the recipient of the 2016 asme
adaptive structures and material Systems
price and spie
2017 Smart structures and materials
Lifetime Achievement and he was named a
Siam fellow in 2018 his research areas
include mathematical modeling of smart
material systems numerical analysis and
methods for physical assistance patient
model collaboration sensitivity analysis
control and uncertainty quantification
of physical and biological systems today
Ralph will talk about parameter software
selection and active Subspace techniques
for engineering and biological models
which is a very interesting topic so
please enjoy it now without further Ado
let me pass the button to Ralph by
asking one random question as usual
today's random question is what is your
favorite things to do other than
research you can answer this question
and then start the present
oh my gosh I didn't see that one coming
well first of all thank you so much for
the invitation to speak here um I had to
check back I was there in 2018 I had a
fantastic visit I met several people and
it's just such an honor to be back with
with this group favorite things to do
well I have to warn you up front and
Katie will maybe smile about this my
students sometimes tell me I need to get
a life uh they're correct but um I
played the piano
um oh a piano since I was five and still
do some volunteer work there and I love
to hike and so one of my favorite
destinations is Colorado getting onto
the 14ers the the Peaks that are over
fourteen thousand feet oh wow nice so
nice you must be pretty good at piano
then I miss you oh gosh it's it's
something I really like kids it's just
where I disappear from the science and
and go to the music so great question
and thank you and again thank you for
the invitation so what I'm gonna do is
gosh it's the Friday before break I'm
gonna kind of keep this a little bit
low-key in case cases I'll probably stop
at various points to ask questions but
um what I'm going to talk about are some
parameter subset selection active
Subspace techniques for large-scale
models and some of this came out of what
was called the doe Consortium for
advanced simulation of light water
reactors which was Castle
Consortium for non-proliferation
enabling capability c-neck Katie Schmidt
is very familiar with that as well as
some more recent initiatives
um
I've got to be right up front here I'm
going to say we a whole lot of times and
we very often is not me it's students
it's postdocs it's colleagues so I think
you can see my cursor there's Katie I'm
going to mention some of what she did on
one slide but I just really want to make
sure that I convey that we very often
was was other people not me
all right so I'm going to look at three
applications
um the first one is
work that came out of Castle this was a
11-year initiative on large-scale models
and it was focused on developing Next
Generation
model environments so here is a new
pressurized water reactor if you fly
into Raleigh from the south you'll see
Sharon Harris Lake
um that's the secondary source that's
the lake water and then you've got the
source that is up against the the
physics and they're separated that's for
a reason just in case something breaches
so in the region
um in the reactor you've got thermal
Hydraulics you've got neutronics you've
got chemistry you've got fuels so it's a
very very large scale multiphysics
multi-scale coupled problem
um one of the things we have to worry
about is this has to be incorporated
into surrogates and we're worrying about
out of data surrogates time time
dependent predict the future so that's a
big deal and one of the things that we
did in this was develop what was called
Vera which was a virtual environment for
reactor applications so we don't we we
as in the community I warned you about
this this Royal wheat the community is
focusing heavily on
things like digital twins I'll talk
about this at the end but simulation
based environments to guide experiments
to guide design to get the the guide
some of the reactor physics but we're
not replacing experiments
okay so one of the motivations for this
analysis is the 3D Neutron transport
equation so we just finished a modeling
class that I teach we know conservation
of stuff stuff here is Neutron transport
so changing stuff is transport in and
then all of these reactions
um I've got the the sigmas are cross
sections so I've got sources we've got
various cross-sections and these can be
extremely high dimensional
um 100 000 inputs when discretized and
and not all of those are influential
this is going to motivate some of the
active Subspace
so when I wait to say we here this was
former students
um Ali Kayla will Point more to that
we then build the act the surrogate
bottle on the active Subspace I'll talk
about that and I point out that some of
the Oak Ridge National Lab codes take
minutes to hours to run so when we do
things like Bayesian inference and say
oh we need a million simulations we have
to build a surrogate and occasionally we
have adjoints all right so that's one
application
the second one excuse me is very very
simple my modeling class knows this
really well they just saw it on their
final and it's a disease model and the
reason I'm pointing to this is a it's
been all over the news for the last
three years modifications of this were
developed for covid
a little bit more complex but not too
much and it illustrates some of what we
worry about when we do uncertainty
analysis sensitivity analysis Etc so we
have a population where we have
susceptible infectious and recovered
that's the sir you start with
susceptibles in the blue you have a few
infected here I started with a hundred
the susceptible population decreases the
infected increases and here's a model
for it all right so in the model we have
these two parameters gamma and K one of
them is the infection coefficient K is
the interaction coefficient all right
and the appears of products so if we're
doing parameter estimation these always
appear as a product I cannot uniquely
Define the two of them but the reason
they appear in the model is the
interaction coefficient unfortunately we
all know really well about that that's
one that we can control
um social distancing quarantine Etc
that's one that that we use as the
population can control the infection
coefficient gamma not so much that's a
property of the disease and so very
often these models will split the two
because we're very interested in
policies how do we specify interactions
and the goal of sensitivity
identifiability analysis is to say how
do we isolate a subset of parameters
that we can determine from data now here
it's trivial I look at the model and say
well these two appears a product in
general we cannot do that that's the
motivation for what we're doing
and the third model I'm going to point
to is a minimal pbbk model that's always
hard to say when you're giving a talk
but it's a physiologically based
pharmacokinetic model of the brain
um minimal because the original model
had a hundred ordinary differential
equations and
a lot of parameters this one has 16
ordinary differential equations
everything coupled and 36 parameters and
you've got four basic compartments
plasma brain lymph and tissue but in
here we have a lot of subcompartments
vascular various brain compartments and
the idea here is to understand
antibiotic exposure to proper dosage
regimes and one of the big goals in this
community is to take digital twins which
is everywhere in the engineering
community and build what they call
virtual populations or v-pops and the
idea in a virtual population is to
determine parameters so that the model
accurately reflects
your population and that may be
different in different areas and then
use the model for virtual testing
virtual simulations
um it's safer it's cheaper and then once
you have a prototype or a possibility
then use that for experimental testing
okay so that's the third one the fourth
example
is one that I'll carry along that we've
looked at again I've worked in smart
materials forever this is
um comes from density functional Theory
and it's a really simple equation it's
the Landau energy it determines where
you have atomic structure so here is let
certainly titanate it is the drive
mechanism in every Atomic Force
microscope because it's extremely
precise however it also has lead and so
you cannot use it in the bile in the the
body it's toxic so there's a lot of work
to say partly cliche can we get the lid
out can we replace this with other
materials that are nearly as good and
what the Landau energy does is it says
here are lead atoms pure oxygen and
where does the zirconium titanium go and
it's stable at that point it's stable at
this point and it's unstable in between
we modeled that with this six loader
differential equation where I have a
quadratic with coefficient that's
negative so I have a concave down
quadratic a cortic that's positive so
concave up cortic and a positive sixth
order
and the question comes up is the six
order term necessary
um can we get along without it I've seen
papers that go up through 12th order
terms and I always ask that question
when I review them uh are these
significant so the objective is can we
insert use uncertainty quantification
sensitivity analogist analysis to bridge
the scales
and we'd love to go from Quantum to
system
um not sure we'll see it in the next
several years but one of the
kind of Holy Grail inverse problems is
then to say all right given a system
application what molecular structure do
I need and in this case it would be can
I replace lead with something that is
less toxic but performs nearly as well
and here's some of the applications
Atomic Force microscopy this appears in
most new Automotive carburetors and it's
a sensor in an airbag these are both
sensing and actuating okay so there are
some of the applications now where we
often go and this is really Elementary
we're at the end of the the year so very
Elementary when I teach modeling the
first place we start when we develop a
spring equation is a linear constituent
relation stress which is Sigma is
proportional to strain lowercase e with
a proportionality constant often goes by
the Young's modulus it depends on the
units but capital E and then we also
have
velocity dependent damping and that
makes sense if you ride a bike uh the
the force of the wind is going to be
more if you're riding faster I ride
pretty slow now so that's not such an
issue but you've got damping this
proportional to Velocity to EDT with a
coefficient C and I'm going to take
nominal values my modulus I'm going to
take to be 100 I'm not worrying about
the units damping coefficient 0.1 a
typical strain is 0.1 percent so .001
and I'm going to take the strain rate of
0.1 and the question would be
to which parameter
modulus or damping is the stress most
sensitive and the place we would often
start is to say okay let's just look at
the derivative of my response with
respect to the two parameters so
derivative with respect to capital E
well that's just the strain is .001
derivative with respect to damping
that's 0.1
easy conclusion more down more sensitive
to damping
um
there's a number of limitations to this
it does not accommodate uncertainty
it it's just derivative there's no just
but it's derivatives uh it doesn't
accommodate potential correlation and
it's really sensitive to units and
that's a big deal we often will switch
units or magnitude so
the next step on that would be say all
right let's take a slightly more Global
Perspective and again this is just
repeating my problem I've got this
linear model in values and I'm going to
vary my parameters 10 about the nominal
values
I'm going to choose a uniform
distribution and my nominal for the
modulus was 100 so I'm going to vary
between 90 and 110 similarly vary the
damping and let's just plot what we get
for our distribution so Sigma when I do
that as a function of varies from point
one up to 0.12 and it's got a really
well defined mean value here
on the other hand Sigma is a function of
dapping varies from it's hard to tell
here but
0.10
something up very much there's a lot of
spread but the mean does not vary much
and so we would say oh from this Global
Perspective where I'm sampling out of
the distributions the response is not
very sensitive to damping but that
directly conflicts with what we saw for
local so this I hope illustrates one of
the issues all right so how does one do
this and this is we as in the community
um this often goes by syllable analysis
or variance-based analysis
um it's frightening how many times we as
in the community has thought oh we're
going to develop this new relation and
then you look in the literature and some
will published it with a comment of this
follows kind of obviously
um he was just a a true leader in this
field so what we would do there is take
our parameters
uniform I'm going to assume independent
so I'm just going to say all right let's
just take my space to be 0 1 to whatever
number of parameters I have and we
expand it in a series so I have my
response is a mean value
and first order interactions and so on
so we look at a series
um the analogy on this would be Taylor
or more more of aptly Fourier and with
Fourier we know we have to have some
kind of constraint the constraint is we
take orthogonal bases Sines and cosines
and we have to have constraints here but
what we do and we do do that is I have
my mean as the average so that's pretty
easy to see if I go 0 1 I integrate over
0 1 and there's the average that's easy
to calculate the problem is
a p dimensional and for example with the
pharmacokinetic model P was on the order
of 16 I'm integrating over R16 and
suddenly we start to see one of the
extremely big challenges of this type of
sensitive analysis is high dimensional
integration
the first order interactions are
integrated over everything except that
variable so this tilde I says integrate
over everything except that variable
subtract the mean and the reason people
do that is you can then form the partial
variance and when you square this you've
got basically the mean squared minus the
average of the entire thing squared and
the total variance and you form what are
called subal indices which is the ratio
so with this expansion I immediately get
the partial variance total variance and
the way you would interpret that is to
say okay back to this example that I
just looked at
I'm looking at the variance of the mean
it goes from 0.1 up to 0.12 it varies
more for this example and that is an
intuitive I hope explanation of why
people would look at this method now
independent parameters kind of keep that
one in the back of your mind
all right this is a kind of a more
technical side I'm not going to belabor
it but you can do this more generally
using um multi-index notation integrate
up through all of your variables and say
okay this what looks like an absolute
value is just the magnitude going from 1
up to P integrate over all of these if
they're independent I should have put
that part in Red 2 then I can write down
the variance in terms of these partial
variances and write syllable indices so
it's a really elegant way to write this
for p variables
again I showed it for two on
this slide this takes it up for p
I don't want to deliver the notation but
there we go okay
um
to quote one of my very good friends
Alice and Wilson the statistics here
what could possibly go wrong
okay and that was an evil laugh I didn't
even write that on that label so let's
go back to our model four quantum and
form continue a model it was this
quadratic with a negative coefficient
quartic and sixth quarter
there's the plot and we do this
sensitivity analysis I've got three
parameters Alpha One double one and
triple one and the solo indices for the
first two are an order of magnitude
bigger than for the third one and they
add up to one that's kind of a big deal
because that says we've we've
accumulated everything here's a total
the add up to one I didn't say anything
about Morrison disease this is an
average of the derivative
the difference there not so much 0.07.03
not sure I'd want to make a decision
based on that but based on syllable 0.39
versus 0.01
we'd say that alpha-111 is insignificant
we fix it for future analysis and off we
go
except what would Allison say what could
possibly go wrong
um so here's what happens
so we perform a Bayesian inference with
different distributions
and when we vary all of them I get this
blue that's when I vary all the the
parameters and then I fix alpha-111
which I said oh the analysis says it's
non-influential that means that it
doesn't really impact our our response
and I get very different results
and what that says is something went
wrong it's not really non-influential
what went wrong well
remember I kept kind of saying with the
Assumption of independent
kept kind of going back to that these
parameters are dependent they're
correlated
um here's the pairwise plots and they've
got a very strong negative correlation
between Alpha One and Alpha 1 1 positive
between Alpha One and Alpha triple one
and we just totally ignored that and I
love pointing this example out to my
students of
if you ignore your hypotheses
things can go badly and here's where it
went badly okay so how do we address
this well there are extensions to this
General formulation and again this is
with this multi-index notation that
accommodate the covariate structure
that's really cool
the problem is you can get Negative
indices because covariances
that one's going to be negative
and so you can get Negative indices from
this
and it's really hard to interpret
negative indices because we were just
going on the fact that they add to one
but negative just really makes it hard
to interpret it's often difficult to
find the underlying distribution
and you have to do Monte Carlo
approximation which is often extremely
expensive okay so there are some issues
there what do we do
alternative parameter subset selection
I'll talk about that active Subspace
techniques and both of these accommodate
parameter correlation
so that's that's where we're headed so
what I'll do is I'll talk about
parameter subset selection and then stop
for questions
so the motivation of parameter subset
selection is back to our model 2 the
very simple disease model where I had
this interaction coefficient and
infection coefficient
the four parameters are not uniquely
determined data by data because they
appear as this product and I look at an
observation model we always come back to
the observation model it's the same
place you'd go for Bayesian inference
and I'm taking the infected which I just
plotted here
that's my infected code thing I assume
that I've got measurement errors
all right so I I've got data which is
plotted as the blue dots the solid line
is the model and then I've got
observation errors and there's a lot of
sources for this especially with the
disease models did people accurately
correct did they do their covet test
accurately dot dot dot
so we start with this observation model
and then we make this statement or
observation not the statement the
observation that not identifiable or
non-influential parameters are those
that have minimal influence on my model
and again in the previous case that was
the infected individuals so pictorially
if I am doing this around the nominal
value Theta star and at perturb it I see
very little difference in the slope wow
that was what we just looked at for
local sensitivity analysis so that
that's intuitive
if I'm looking at two parameters the
level curves are about the same
so the motivation on this is to say all
right
let's consider a Taylor expansion it
always comes back to this for non-linear
models about this nominal value Theta
star I could get that either from
optimization or I can do this with
simulated data and I've got the
perturbations this is the gradient and
perturbations
and then we look at the functional
that's the difference between the data
Yi and the model that's just the least
squares and again we can do this with
optimization but we often use
um we often use synthetic data so
there's the the motivation do a
parameter subset or do a a Taylor
expansion okay this slide is busy but a
lot of it's repeating I did my Taylor
expansion I've got this least squares
functional now
what we just said is if this is a
nominal value and I'm minimizing this
functional y i is pretty close to the
model at the nominal value
either a generated synthetic data that
way or I optimized so if I look at my
gradient here
this value right here is very close to y
i I'm left with the gradient times the
perturbation so my perturbation in in J
which is the functional is approximately
the gradient
times the perturbations quantity squared
all right and what we can do is rewrite
that in terms of the sensitivity Matrix
S
okay so what is that going to be S is
the derivatives of my model
with respect to Theta 1 through Theta P
at different time values
we're going to come back to how we
calculate that but there's a sensitivity
Matrix and its sensitivity Matrix
transpose sensitivity Matrix that is
this product
all right here's another bit of the
intuition we'd say okay this is my
penalty functional remember over here
we're looking at cases where the values
are pretty close level curves are
derivatives
so I say all right let's Express J in
terms of eigenvectors and eigenvalues of
s transpose s which is the scaled
Fischer information Matrix It
incorporates parameter correlation
so remember if that's the case I've got
s transpose s take that to be an
eigenvector as Lambda times
the value and that just says that my
penalty is eigenvalues times this Square
okay so if our eigenvalues were
approximately zero perturbations are
approximately zero it's non-identifiable
that's the intuition that's the picture
I just drew right here
cool
all right so we're looking at a value
and value problem now
a little bit of history on this
um Computing eigenvalues of s transpose
s if you talked about linear algebra
colleagues they sort of stand up
straight because you get small
eigenvalues it's more numerically
efficient to instead look at the
singular value or QR of s rather than
that transpose s
Christmas tree
there's this beautiful paper by Reed in
1977 he was in the control Community
where he said oh parameters data or
sensitivity identifiable if s is one to
one
or the null space of s transpose s is s
at the 1977.
all right getting to point to Katie and
some of her work from 2016 she looked at
parameter subset selection for mixed
effects models there's a beautiful paper
that she wrote in the international
Journal of uncertainty quantification
this is mixed effects I won't be able to
talk about but it's really important
talk to her about this it's when you
have individual effects in a population
so there's a bit of the background and
back to our sir model we do this we look
at the rank it's three and that makes
sense because of these four parameters
gambling K are not jointly identifiable
okay
however there's no free lunch it
requires gradient approximations
because I've got this
sensitivity Matrix
and it's local
all right so let's talk about the
gradient approximations and this is
perhaps the coolest next two slides of
the talk
um
we're going to use complex step
derivative approximations
and this goes way back it's discussed in
a paper by lynescent Mohler I always
have to point out to my my students that
Mohler was the person who basically
embedded Matlab in 1967.
well they looked at analytic functions
uh and basically what it says is if you
have a smooth F doesn't have to be
analytic but smooth and you do a complex
perturbation rather than a real
perturbation look at the Taylor series
on this
you get the following Taylor series and
then you approximate the derivative F
Prime by the imaginary part of this
perturbation divided by h
and when you do that you've got an order
H squared error
all right so there's two things to
notice about this
there's no subtractive cancellation if I
did a Taylor expansion I've got f of x
plus the perturbation minus f of x it
limits its accuracy the Taylor expansion
is also order H so a really classical
example is to say all right if I do a
finite difference I'm order H it's this
black line until the square root of
machine Epsilon and then I
come back out and it's inaccurate
this approximation is order H squared
until you get to basically machine
Epsilon and then it stays here
there's no subtractive cancellation
it's incredibly robust we use step size
to 10 to the minus 14 which you could
never ever do with a finite difference
and I have to believe so this is a 1967
reference I have to believe this is
something that someone like Fourier
looked at and thought yeah that's really
cool and then didn't even write it out
but it's really really impressive when
it works
okay so I'm going to illustrate this on
the mpbk this is work by Kamala
datashova 16odes 36 parameters
um and one way to verify this is compare
complex step for your sensitivities and
sensitivity equations sensitivity
equation you differentiate your model
with respect to the parameters
um it took her several days to code the
sensitivity equations it took her about
15 minutes to do the complex step and
they match they're very very close
and it requires two lines of Matlab code
you take a complex perturbation and you
keep the imaginary part
accuracy is dictated by this OD solver
it doesn't always work and if you're
using things like the pde toolbox they
have analytic function capabilities but
when it works it's really really really
cool
okay
back to her problem this is the
parameter subset selection for this
minimal model she considered five dose
regimes
it turned out from the 36 parameters non
were nine were non-identifiable
so then the verification on this was to
randomly sample the remaining ones
fix the non-identifiable and this is a
visual comparison so all of them
randomly sampled fix the random and you
get a very close match
okay that's parameter subset selection
still local
but
it is a very very powerful way to look
at these types of problems okay so I'm
going to spend the remainder of the time
talking about active subspaces they look
similar
um but it might be good at this point
just to see if there's questions and
then of course we'll entertain questions
at the end but this is kind of the end
of part one but let's let's see if
there's questions at this point
okay
um and let's see it's a little hard for
me let me see if I can do my chat on the
other side yeah I can um I can press it
right um okay so the Rob asked about
okay Ralphie's sister uh oh she's very
brilliant and that's it can you expound
uh upon the methodology limitations yeah
he seems to have a general applicability
yeah no no that's a great question
um and great to see you rob
um yeah it doesn't it it's not a Panacea
for everything so the original
formulation required analytic the Taylor
expansion you still require smoothness
but um it doesn't have to be analytic it
people have pushed it up to
discontinuities and it does well up to a
discontinuity you have to be a little
bit careful about some codes so for
example the absolute value in some
languages is the modulus and the modulus
may be interpreted slightly differently
be a little bit careful there in Matlab
we have found it to be really robust but
places where one has to be pretty
careful are
um pde toolbox it'll have trouble
because uh there's analytic function
capabilities uh the neural net toolbox
also has some complex algebra in it so
one has to be a little bit careful about
places where you have those types of
limitations but as long as the complex
algebra is robust it's been pretty hard
to break
um
the thing that we always always Advocate
is verification verification
verification all of my students are hurt
postdocs have heard this compared to
another method
but it is pretty hard to break and it is
starting to gain more traction
um a little bit more of the history so
this one was the first place I've seen a
reference the Aerospace Community picked
it up in gosh around 1990s and used it
pretty heavily there Tom banks used it
pretty heavily in math biology about 12
years ago it is gaining traction but
verify that's that's some of the the
limitations and and ideas on it but
great great question
Ralph we have one more question do you
have time to answer absolutely yeah
could you read it yeah uh it's another
question from Mark how does a complex
perturbation affect things like adaptive
step size in ode integration algorithms
oh gosh yeah great question yeah so I
made the comment that the accuracy is
dictated by the
um the accuracy the odds however it
doesn't really affect it so if you set a
say absolute error in your ode solver of
10 to the minus 5
you're going to get the results you're
looking for and I think that was okay
Kamala was using about 10 to the minus
10 here it does not affect that at all
um and again we typically use a step
size on the order of say 10 to the minus
14 we go small
try some others but it does not affect
the ode solvers they seem to be very
very robust with respect to it
so all right well let me gosh great
questions and I just again I I sort of
preface this may be this is really cool
it's there's that old adage of it sounds
too good to be true that may be the case
this one is pretty good
all right let me talk a bit about active
subspaces and then we can talk in
general at questions so this looks
similar but it gives you subspaces
rather than subsets so here's an example
from Paul Constantine's book
um it's this linear combination 0.7 q1
0.3 Q2 exponential and obviously they're
linearly related
so here is the linear Subspace there's
no variation in the orthogonal direction
and so what we would do is look for
these subspaces and put all of the heavy
lifting onto the linear algebra
techniques
all right I always like pointing out
history because
um this is very often and correctly
attributed to Russian around 2010 Paul
Constantine did an amazing job of
conveying this to the community in a way
that just I think showed its strengths
in addition to what rusi did
um remember that paper by read I I
quoted it right before I I quoted
Katie's stuff this is the same as an
identifiable Subspace locally that's a
big difference but locally
for non-linear problems and if it's a
linear problem yikes that one's hard
because it's SVD and QR and I had to do
some searching there's this beautiful
review paper in 1993 by Stewart that
talks about SVD QR but I hope this gives
the hint that finding these subspaces
puts all of the heavy lifting onto the
linear algebra and these are these are
amazing techniques SVD QR are incredibly
robust
okay so this one's a little bit mathy
we'll get to some examples in a few
minutes so I've got a non-linearly
parameterized problem I've got gradients
we just talked about that
um Paul has a beautiful Siam Frontiers
book in 2015 Miro and click Webster uh
International Journal of uncertainty
qualification same Journal I mentioned
for Katie earlier uh paper and you
construct an outer product
gradient gradient and a distribution
that's kind of a big deal let me go to
the next one how tip sensitive are the
results of this distribution not very
but tested
and this gradient gradient oh this looks
a lot like
parameter subset selection except for
averaging it
okay I'm going to describe this in terms
of eigenvalues because I just motivated
parameter subset selection that way but
we typically do it in terms of the
singular values for the reasons I
mentioned but for the eigenvalues I look
for a break
talk a little about that or breaking the
eigenvalues split the eigenvectors at
that same dimension
and that gives me a Subspace of active
variables
and the complement of the inactive
okay so small eigenvalues are inactive
small singular values inactive
okay so the algorithm on this and then
we're going to get to a bit more of the
examples are we have to discretize this
and this is kind of a big deal this is
um this is where the the Monte Carlo
sampling comes in
we would typically only form
the sensitivity Matrix we talked about
that for parameter subset selection take
the SVD and look at the first n
dimensions
right it's tempting to finite
differences it's not effective it just
it's not accurate enough at high D
strategy is employee complex step and
gradient free algorithms here's where
I'm going to point to we being Ali and
Kayla
uh and the example that they looked at
was back to the nuclear example promised
I was going to come back to that this is
um that the nuclear example we're
looking at a dimension 7 700. it's not a
hundred thousand but it's pretty high
dimension and we look at K effective and
K effective determines whether reactions
go forward or they don't okay effective
greater than one k effective less than
one forward if it's there when you
discretize your reactions these are all
again cross-sections fishing cross
sections etc etc and materials You've
Got 7 700
and I just point out that these
cross-section libraries are binary and
you have to do a conversion and that was
something that on the math side we had
to be really careful about that again we
being Ally and Kayla here
so the results on this
were to say all right 7700
skill evaluations this was the code we
were using gradient based required a
thousand
the algorithm that they used required
eighteen thousand
and projected finite difference
projected finite difference was seven
million we couldn't do it because
you just don't have the computational
budgets for that
all right and this one's a nice test
problem because you have analytic
eigenvalues of one and zero one is the
reaction proceeds zero is a dozen the
black are the gradient based the red of
the initialize the the the new algorithm
um and you have one eigenvalue of one
and then you see it dropped to zero
and it turns out that this
new algorithm was more accurate and the
reason for that is Computing converged
stat joint Solutions was often not
achieved it's one of these things where
the code the people will say yes we have
an adjoin code
but getting them to converge is hard all
right so what was the dimension it
started at 7 700
we would use gradient based which gave a
dimension one active Subspace we went
from 7700 to 1.
principal component analysis was either
two or one depending on the cutoff and
for surrogate sampled off for a
tolerance of 10 to the minus three it's
a one-dimensional Subspace
two if you go higher
that is a big deal we go from 77 to 1
and building a a surrogate on 1D is
really really easy so that's a very
large scale example now in the last five
minutes I just want to talk about
Bayesian inference here and where we
might use that so back to Paul's example
this linear combination 0.7 times first
parameter 0.3 times a second they're not
jointly identifiable
so what we did this being we was Ali was
took uniform distributions in Black
and the reason you take uniform is when
you rotate a uniform it's uniforms I'm
sorry the reason we use normal
distributions
I said uniform I meant normal is when
you rotate a normal you stay normal
okay so the normal was in black and we
just did easy difference see how it
works and what you find is the
full space
looks like it's informing the first
parameter not so much the second
and when you look at the pairwise you
get exactly this non-identifiable
Subspace here's the paired wise plot
it's single value that indicates four
points on this line
they give the same likelihoods they're
not identifiable and that makes sense
there it is
okay so what we want to do is say can we
use active subspaces to understand and
do Bayesian inference
and you can so
here's the example form the gradient
Matrix we've talked a couple of times
about that take the SVD
here's my singular values corresponding
singular vectors
and either the eigenvalue or a singular
value indicates a 1D active Subspace and
here would be the basis for it
0.91.39
all right so if you do inference on the
active Subspace what you would do is say
okay I've got a 1D active Subspace
I sample values on here and fit a
response okay so there it is I've got
training points in red
I fit my model to it yep it's an
exponential I have test points in blue
so I
construct
and validate verify perform Bayesian
inference on this 1D Subspace gosh it's
Bayesian inference on 1D that's easy
because it's invariant we can just
randomly draw to fill out the 2D space
from normal zero one and then we
transform back because when we work with
the nuclear Engineers they don't care
about transform variables they want
physical variables
okay
final step that we look at on here is
say okay we did the unprints how do we
understand this a little better well
here was the prior in Black
the full space in the reduced space
restrict what we get for the first
parameter not so much for the second and
to get a sensitivity measure on that we
go back to work that Paul Constantine
did and said well what you can form are
these activity scores which are either
Eiger eigen or singular values and
vectors and look at the squares of the
components so I just said oh on the
previous slide I got the 0.91 for the
first 0.39 for the second I Square these
the first one is going to be influential
it's going to be informed during
inference the second is not and the
results show that
okay let's look at a real example and
finish with questions
so
a little bit more mathy it's a family of
elliptic equations this could be
Acoustics it could be groundwater flow
whatever your favorite thing is you
could think about groundwater flow at a
on a rectangular domain and at various
Heights so I have elliptic differential
equations again this is steady state so
groundwater flow acoustics
you could look at electromagnetics and I
have n different heights
I have a random field a so I represent
it in terms of a cartoon on the web
expansion think for a if you haven't
seen that but I just represent it
and my quantity of interest is going to
be the strain at the N different levels
so I integrate and get the strain at
these n different levels there's the
model
when you do your expansion in terms of
the cartoon on the web my Dimension is
91. it's pretty high dimensional
the active Subspace Dimension is three
because I constructed that way and this
is a funded element discrimination on it
all right so we look at our singular
values and remember we constructed it
with three if I look at the singular
values I've got three that are
almost two orders of magnitude larger
than the others and that we this was a
verification we knew that by
Construction
we then construct the activity scores
and there's three of them that are again
gosh two orders of magnitude larger than
the others and they correspond to
parameters 1 38 and 66. so what this
says is those parameters will be
informed during Bayesian inference the
others not so much
so 138 and 66.
okay we being Ally and
and Brian on this so again the prior is
the black
gaussian prior is in all cases here is
not sure why I switched the order but 38
66 and one and in all cases the
posterior
is much narrower than the prior
so and the reduced space this is doing
it on the active Subspace here's my
posterior much more narrow than the
prior we've been doing a good job on
this
just to test this Ali then said let's
test parameters 40 68 and 6 and 3. and
here what we find is doing inference on
the reduced space you do not inform your
prior at all that means you're just
getting no identifiability here in any
of these cases under a new space the
full space looks like it is and that's
erroneous and we ask why is that and
just to point out the full space
computations took 18 the reduced space
took 20 seconds it's a big time
difference and here's the full space 18
hours the chains are
sort of converging but not really you've
got these stagnating regions here's a
stagnating region here's a stagnating
region here
um it's not terrible but the full space
inference is just not reliable
the active Subspace I've got a colleague
here named Brian rich and every student
in my class and his nose you look for
chains that look like fuzzy caterpillars
and there's your fuzzy caterpillars
These Chains look great the active
Subspace is doing what it's supposed to
we're informing three of the parameters
the remainder are not we go back to the
nuclear engineers and say that's what
you can do with this model
okay let's let's get some concluding
remarks answer questions discussed so uh
parameter sub selection really really
nice to identify to isolate identifiable
influential parameters and it
accommodates parameter dependencies I
didn't really emphasize this but it
focuses on well if you do the
eigenvalues it's official information
Matrix if you can invert that it's
proportional to The covariance Matrix so
it accommodates dependencies
active Subspace this is a subset
some space builds a Subspace of these
and you can go very high dimensional
complex step ah gosh give it a try
um send the email I'll send you
references when it works it's really
really good
we live by surrogate models um that
that's sort of just a given we often use
that our computational budget to
construct and verify
and then we work with that
um
I want to kind of just get on my control
background
soapbox and say a lot of synergy between
what I talked about uncertainty
quantification sensitive analysis and
control design and so that's one of my
big pushes right now is to keep bringing
some of these two areas together
um I've mentioned virtual Twins and
virtual populations and so on
gosh this goes back to probably that
well not probably NASA with Apollo 13.
was the first place at a virtual a
digital twin was used where they took
data they updated their models they
provided a set of instructions to bring
back Apollo 13. it's huge right now
um for everyone who's been following
Artemis they're doing digital digital
twins here uh it's pretty much
everywhere in engineering
um my colleague Nom did in nuclear
engineering has built a beautiful
scenario for building a digital twin of
a nuclear power plant for parts that are
hard to test one of the places we're
looking at is the Mars return Mission
and probably a good place to stop here
is
prediction is very difficult especially
if it's about the future because you're
extrapolating
um
I'm old
I first heard Yogi Berra say this and he
did but Niels bore said at the same time
it's a Danish proverb but here's where
we're going is out of we're doing
extrapolatory predictions out of data
predictions these are the types of
predictions we're looking at okay so
there's an overview of these topics I'd
love to entertain questions again thank
you so much for the chance to being able
to visit with you all and let's just
open up for general questions now thank
you thank you so much for the wonderful
talk yeah let's go let's do the Q a
session
um yeah if you could read the chat it's
I I've got it over on my laptop but it's
kind of weird but if you can read that
and then just unmute yourself and and
say hi and let me know questions that
way as well exactly exactly yeah please
feel free to unmute yourself and um you
know speak for yourself yeah
I don't have any questions in the in the
chat room okay good auditions
yeah let's unmute and let's just open up
the general discussion and one of the
ones I wanted the the virtual the
digital twins that I actually usually
goes by digital Twins and virtual
populations I should probably correct
that but
are people there working on that because
again it just seems like a special issue
of every engineering Journal right now
is
focused on this yeah yeah
um as a matter of fact I miss this a
couple of uh you know the internal
funding projects at Lawrence Livermore
National Lab it's it's all about digital
twins so
so there are folks who are working on
the digital Twins and and many many
folks who work on the videos to the
model um including me and it's that's
the you know that's aiming for the
digital twins as well right it it is and
and one of the things that I often point
out and again you guys are working on
this and more Ground Zero but I've had
colleagues say wow um it's just model
calibration I've been doing digital
twins my whole career but the place
where I look at it is somewhat different
is it really is
you're really building unique models for
a specific entity and it's also some
beautiful kind of incorporations of
machine learning to say where do I
collect the data and collect new data
that I need
in order to update that so for those who
may not be familiar with it it
it really goes beyond model calibration
to this
incredibly complete picture of how do we
build a numerical representation for a
specific entity and update it as that
entities as as its life progresses but
yeah I'm talking too much I want to hear
hear from you guys
all right sounds good okay
um
um I I can ask questions so one of the
topics you covered was the actives of
space methods um and you successfully
apply that uh for you know the examples
with the primary space of you know 7700
as you've indicated in this uh in this
slide
um
it's a it depends on the the successful
application of active Subspace is depend
depending on that activation the you
know the factor how much you can
truncate and still get the good
representations using the gradient and
if that is not the case then active
Subspace
um will not work right yeah no you're
absolutely right I mean it's it's based
on linearization and gosh so many of
these methods for nonlinear problems are
based on a linearization so you really
want to try and get the linearization as
accurate as you can
um and for a lot of the codes we've
looked at they do have adjoints and that
would be the immediate place we'd start
with would be an adjoint uh that's where
I wanted to point for to complex step
and some of these other approximation
methods but no you're absolutely right
it all of these methods for non-linear
problems depend on linearization and you
want to get that as accurate as you can
right right yeah
and and another extension would be is is
there you know non-linear version of
active actives of space
um yeah okay I'm gonna take that
question and pose it as a future
question for the community
um so a sort of a non-linear version is
parameter subset selection
um and again we're still calculating
gradients
um but we're not doing the Subspace
parameter subset selection is local
right now it's at a point the obvious
thing to try is averaging it and we did
and sometimes that works but you can
also write down counter examples
um but but no I I think there's a lot of
work to be done on extending this to
parameter subset selection techniques
again it's a linearization but it's a
different philosophy you're looking for
subsets rather than subspaces
um as far as going with the non-linear
itself I
in specific cases you can deal with the
non-linearities but so often the
techniques I know about are linearizing
somehow
and that's where I took it back to the
first one was when you linearize in
active subspaces you're averaging over
some some space
how can you do that for parameter subset
selection and the reason one of the
reasons after talking with you I'd want
to show those math biology examples but
this is really important there because
the non-linearities in some of these
these math biology models are
tremendously they're very non-linear
there's delays Etc and the companies
non-linearities is a big deal and and so
I think there's a lot of work to be done
for working with the truly non-linear
models when we have to keep track of the
nonlinearities
[Music]
and I mean that's just always the case
when you linearizes gosh what are you
losing in the process
thank you rob there there's a question
in the chat room uh by Boyer he's asking
uh can the active Subspace approach be
applied to General regression problem to
do variable selection or variable
importance rankings
yeah no broadly it can
um and one of the things that let me see
if I can go back really really quickly
is active subspaces does give you
these activity scores and and thank you
I love these kinds that do give you a
measure of global sensitivity
um and so you can get a measure of
global sensitivity there's relations and
balance between these and Sobel indices
so you can get Global sensitivity
rankings and use that for parameter
selection
um and and still go into original space
but but the answer is yes and and work
in the original
non-linear space
um I I showed what happens when we find
a Subspace of values but you can use
this to just rank parameters so great
question I probably didn't emphasize
that enough but that that's where we
look at the activity scores
thank you thank you rob
um
is there any other question from
audiences
I have a question hi Ralph this is Mark
transstrom here yeah how are you Mark
I'm doing great it's a very nice talk
thank you very much oh no gosh it's so
good to get back with with this group
thank you so uh I was kind of struck by
the the plot you showed that had the the
eigenvalues of the the C Matrix that
comes out of the active Subspace
analysis uh where you have the very
large gap that you can clearly see these
are the things that matter and there's a
clear distinction between the the active
and the inactive the the important to
the unimportant you know so much of my
other work in um looking at eigenvalue's
official information matrices where we
talk about sloppy analysis we see uh
plots that sort of look like this but we
often see eigenvalue spread over many
orders of magnitude without a gap
anywhere oh my gosh yeah we always have
this problem there's obviously things
that are unimportant but there's no
clear distinction between the important
and the unimportant
and so that's the question that we The
Dilemma that we're always grappling with
and I'm just curious if you have any
experience similar experiences with that
or insights into how you would handle
such a scenario oh my gosh yeah Mark I
love questions like that because yes we
have exactly the same experience this
one was obvious
um there it is boom and we also this one
where we did this one was pretty obvious
however when we do these types of
examples for
the math biology it's exactly what you
see you see a decay in singular values
and then you start saying is that a gap
or is that really not
um and so the best thing I so yes we've
seen it it comes up on these math
biology examples a lot
um the best thing I know to do on that
and this is we as in Kamal has been
doing a lot of this is saying okay let's
start fixing there's obvious parameters
to fix we fix those and then we do some
kind of a verification step where we
randomly perturb parameters all of the
parameters and those that are fixed and
we see if we get the same distributions
or you can quantify this using energy
statistics and and please send an email
if you'd like more information on the
energy statistic but yeah we've
definitely seen the scenarios that
you're pointing out and the best that I
know to do on that is say okay we've got
to go in and then let's start working
our way down into those less clear
parameters fix them vary our response
see what we get
and that kind of a verification step
either qualitative or quantitative is
the only way I know to answer that at
this point but you're right it comes up
and it it's something we see a lot on
these and perhaps this kind of goes back
to your question uh earlier very
non-linear models yes it does come up
and the best I know is to try and do
that kind of a verification
thank you for putting that out because
yeah I made it look so obvious and those
were best cases on these problems you
really have to you get into this sort of
great regime and you then have to go
through parameter by parameter in some
cases and just test it
great thanks
thank you rob um there's one more
question do you have a time I've got
plenty of time my next meeting is not
for an hour I made sure to leave a time
slot here this is I I this is the kind
of the highlight of the day is talking
with you guys let's go with questions
please all right all right sounds good
okay uh another question from Marco he
says um great talk do you have some
experience in using slice the inverse
regression Sil for this kind of problems
to identify self-spaces
I don't and my request Marco is please
send me a reference on that I I'd love
to see more about it and this kind of
goes for everybody please if you've got
questions things I'm the only Smith in
mathematics at NCSU I'm easy to find
um I know several of you but I'd love to
see references in that I'm afraid I'm
not familiar with it and I'd love to see
references so please send the email and
let let's communicate I'd love to see
what you're more about that
um
sounds good one of the motivations of
this this talk is to you know you know
uh to facilitate more collaboration with
EU and the boxing Lawrence with monies
in the left so actually I saw the
um you know you know in in the beginning
slides there's you have the
collaboration with us India National Lab
and Los Alamos but you're missing
Lawrence Livonia no you're going to do a
better job
one of the reasons I was thrilled when
you contacted me to speak for many many
reasons that I just thrilled and so
honored but one of them is I'd love to
keep building those collaborations and
the reason for the Sandia Lawrence
Livermore or I'm sorry Sandia and let me
go back to the beginning was Los Alamos
was these doe initiatives
and so a lot of that was that came out
of the the doe initiatives but no I I
Lawrence Livermore I again I've I've got
some some very well former students and
and very close colleagues there um I'd
love to keep building these
collaborations that that was one of the
reasons I was so grateful when you you
contacted me to speak so thank you yeah
that's great that's great all right uh
any other questions
from audience
okay
I think we wore folks out well gosh
again thank you so much for the chance
to visit and speak with you and and
please please let's use this as step one
to let's start communicating via email
uh Zoom Etc and let's let's see what we
might be able to build on collaborations
yeah let's do that okay thank you so
much let's um you know give a Applause
to uh our speaker Ralph um it was a
great honor to host you of
and yeah thank you very much let's let's
keep in touch that sounds perfect well
that sounds wonderful let's keep in
touch and then meanwhile have a
wonderful holiday season everyone
likewise yeah care thanks all thank you
bye